hello everyone my name is min Kelly and
I'm also a
HCI background like the previous speaker
oh hi you so I'm really excited to be
here at this workshop because I've been
admiring your work this community work
that tries to formalize different
fairness notions of fairness the work
that I will present today offers a
complementary angle an argue that we
should consider both fairness and
distributive outcomes from the algorithm
but also procedural justice in the way
we design and give control to the end
user who is using and we were affected
by these algorithms before I start the
talk I like to acknowledge that the work
that I will present today was only
possible things to be hard work there
are interdisciplinary team has done over
the past three years so I actually
started my research career as a
human-computer interaction focusing on
robots I've been looking at how people
should can interact with the robot that
deliver is good in the office or being a
helper for the people living
independently in their home but when
uber and lyft was first introduced to
Pittsburgh in 2014 I realized that there
are different kinds of robot emerging in
the world
so there are robot in the uber app yes
they don't have bodies like like the
physical robot that you saw in the
previous slide but they were and they're
making decision autonomously they're on
their own so it was in a way robust but
they are not our colleague or helper
that I'm used to frame in my work now
they are influencing or making decisions
that give jobs to driver and influence
how much they earn so I started calling
this emergence of algorithm a robot or
robotic boss as algorithmic management
and with this community I don't have to
emphasize that this algorithmic
management is integrating into workplace
in the cities are steadily but
increasingly so these a eyes are not
just deciding what we see online they
manage worker routines tasks incentives
and who is offered jobs there were small
loan businesses some small business
loans and this AI is also being applied
to criminal justice systems and
government programs and from human
perspective this context of AI differs
from traditional AI applications in two
ways so first these managerial or
governance contexts involve new type of
users if you get a Netflix
recommendation as a user if you don't
like it you can just ignore it but if
you are workers and get a work
assignment from the algorithm it's more
difficult to say no so this means that
we need to consider both of those who
are affected by a AI decisions like the
workers getting the job from the
algorithm and the management those who
use the AI to make decisions and we
don't we don't yet know enough and
consider how people who are affected by
algorithm feel about this algorithmic
management in emerging evidence suggests
that actually they are not feeling great
about it
so I conducted a study in which I show I
told people that they were selected for
an interview and then said this decision
was based made by a human manager versus
the algorithm and then finding suggests
that people were actually thought that
the the having their resumes cream by
algorithm was less fair less trustworthy
and it provoked a more negative emotion
compared to human decision-makers
majority of people mentioned that they
distrust the algorithm because they
cannot sufficiently in a lie analyze
factors they believe in place of
human-like considering personality or
work cultures so they thought that even
though the algorithm can be objective
and don't have human biases they were
concerned that the accuracy of the
algorithm will not be enough to be used
in this context where the human was I
want to clarify that I wanted to compare
source bias I wanted to know whether the
knowledge of the decision-maker whether
its algorithm or human in itself can
influence the how they view the outcome
so this was done experimentally online
so this was not done in LinkedIn it was
like M trackers online yes they applied
they submitted their resumes and online
and then they again notification they
knew that they were participating in the
experiment as a part of human something
we usually need to inform that they are
doing a study but we didn't tell them
like what we are manipulating so we told
them then you're gonna be in situation
and tell us how you feel so they knew
that there was no job waiting a
dangerous no no they yeah they didn't
know yeah they thought they didn't they
knew that there is no job so this is a
hypothetical and then so this is a first
step toward understanding the
perceptions algorithm but obviously we
need a lot more work yeah but one thing
that was really interesting to me was
that yes it is about concerns of the
accuracy but also the fact that people
can be judged or evaluate by the
algorithm minister
can be dehumanizing freezin one
participant said that I'll feel like a
machine being chosen by a machine so
this shows that it is really important
for us to understand like how we can
make these people who will be affected
by the algorithm feel that they can't
they are still respected in the
workplace the second characteristics of
algorithm management is that it often
mediates multiple stakeholders benefits
and costs from using the service
so as highe mentioned for example
on-demand or platform like uber users
algorithm to assign tasks which affect
their customer their workers and also
the company's own profit and they're
having emerging public concern fears and
some real-world AI evidences that
suggests that these governing AI can be
used as a mechanism of control by the
management and unfairly prioritizes a
small set of stakeholders benefits at
the cost of rest of the stakeholders so
sometimes this is done intentionally and
purposefully like for example the
objective of the Facebook curation
algorithm is to maximize the profits of
the company and satisfy the heirs
provider probably at the cost of the
healthy media consumptions in our
society but many times it is also done
unintentionally because those who build
is algorithm often do not identify these
multiple stakeholders of front a more
importantly they like quantifiable
metrics that define utilities and values
of different stakeholders so the work
that I will present today
seeks to flip this dynamic and ask how
can we empower people to design
algorithmic governance for their own
community and how can your - fairer and
more trustworthy decision than human
decisions from the perspective people
who are affected by these decisions
so the work that I'll present today will
take the first step toward these to
answer these questions I'll first
explain how people perceive a supposed
to be fair algorithm and why procedural
justice framework matters and I will
then explain my true project that
implement different components of the
procedural framework so the first one we
seeks to enable transparency and process
controlling the framework so the
stakeholders can design and build on
average for their own community and I
will present a case study with a real
nonprofit a second project I will
briefly mentioned for a few minutes
where we are exploring the effect of
transparency and I'll control
so I explore the human perceptions of
test collocation when it's done by the
algorithm versus in human and I want to
highlight that we used a fair division
algorithm in this study not general
algorithm or the discriminatory
algorithm they be no make our bias
decision so can certain demographics so
fair division algorithm I think in doing
this audience you should probably are
very familiar with this concept but for
a lot of it Chaldeans it was a very
strange or foreign concept I will give
you a brief overview about it so it's a
subset of AI computer theory economics
and mathematics and they use how much
individual value or dissolve these are
of available resources as individual
utilities and I locate given limited
resources to each person while
maximizing its person's utility and
meeting of some fairness property they
are proven mathematically to guarantee
fairness which means that they satisfy
different properties of fairness in all
cases so for example the property of
envy fairness means that none of the
player was to swap their person with
another because they find all Persians
are equally valuable another property is
max min which maximizes the TVD of the
person who gets the least among the
group so this kind of algorithms have
been using a variety of domains they
traditionally have allocated computer
infrastructure such as network bandwidth
or CPU resources but they are now being
applied to more social domains such as
policymaking organizational management
healthcare education etc
so I wanted to see how people perceive a
location this isn't from this fair
division algorithm compared to human
decision maker in SI unit of study I was
not originally questioning the fairness
of the fair division algorithm in this
lecture I will talk about further
divisions with of course if I don't get
along so I want to clarify that this
particular study the algorithm was not
machine learning base and then the
resources were limited so if you're
saying but the wrong decisions are made
by the likelihood that this person will
pay off the loan or not it's a slightly
different context so this is more about
fairly different wait am i answering
your question I don't know how can you
get entry freeness in a situation where
you have to allocate at all
I always be jealous yeah so for that
context I don't think yes I'm referring
this isn't the right kind of a solution
I don't think this particular MV
freeness applies to the lawns to answer
your question it's more on for example
the allocation of scheduled shift where
you have a limited quota and then you
have and they applying like midst of
allocating the people's shift according
to their preferences or constraint
that's something that this will be
applied same with the Tesco Simon I have
a frame for certain tasks and you need
to divide among the groups then you may
be MP furriness can apply they're known
for binary decision probably not a
pickle
there are several people working and
they have to organize their shifts the
shift that starts at 11:00 a.m.
then there's only one yeah i agree that
their work on there can be contact where
mp3 news cannot be met and especially
for this one when these outcomes in art
continues then i think there is some
comprises macy's and be free up to one
good for example but still there are
contexts if there is only three jobs and
there are hundred people every penis
will be probably impossible you could
have the next aunty where like you you
all have the same probability of the
eleven hands yeah sure but I didn't hear
the phrase that sensitive discussion of
any treatments less so thank you
so for the user active for the exact
concerns like sometimes situations are
unfair so that people will be neighbor
will think the decisions are unfair
whether is from the algorithm or human
for that kind of context right because
of the imbalance between what's
available versus thirteen man so when I
when I first studied this particular
algorithm always were curious are like
how this decision automation impact
group dynamics so I kind of studied a
pilot studies where I
I told allocated a task to people using
the algorithm that we'll talk about
shortly and then people were saying
before talking about dynamic this
allocation is just unfair so I was
talking to people who are create this
algorithm people are saying that there's
a Haridas on there and they were yeah
well people will be never will never
think that any any decision is fair so
that's why is kind of wondered and
applies when you're talking about third
division it's the same group that plays
both rows I mean I want to cake with you
yeah the suppliers and the consumers
it's not they're two different entities
that depending on the contact there can
be two and today like for example
schedule is served it's still the
management who deploy the algorithm then
I don't see how it
the angry furnace comes from the fact
that I'm also the one who allocates the
resource
maybe not only the consumer you should
proceed when she gives the example of
posses then we see this may be to be
satisfied in association with our Python
we need to go on well I've been focusing
on how people perceive the decisions
from this algorithm so actually there
will be not a lot of discussion about
envy freeness here but I love to hear
more thoughts on after this talk yeah so
the yeah so to test these I guess
precision of decisions whether it's made
by the algorithm versus human we wanted
to use a real word test for this one so
we brought people to a kitchen law and
told him that they are sharing on
apartment and had to divide tours to
prepare for house party and half of the
participant used the fair division
algorithm and the other half discussed
among themselves how to allocate the
tasks so we use our website Co splitted
I so made a cm new and each participant
use the interface shown on this slide to
indicate the help they proof how much
they prefer each task as compared to the
baseline tasks by writing multiplier so
here stating how many times they do one
task to avoid another in algorithm dem
assign the tasks to each individual to
minimize each individual's perceived
burden with efficiency and participant
actually had to carry out the chores in
the lab so in retrospective this was a
great time to come to the lab every day
because he was squeaky clean and smell
really nice for a few months we even had
people making our first coffee and
lemonade every
quickly did you ever stop experiment no
I never stopped mixer after they
finished the test each participant
filled out the survey and was
interviewed individually so what did
people say after carrying out the tour's
assigned to them either by algorithm or
through discussion the win algorithm
divided tour participant that the
decisions were only some affair on
average and 40% of them thought that the
outcomes were not fair on the other hand
when people decided who was working on
on what through discussion they thought
that decisions were pretty fair so
overall discussion based outcomes were
generally perceived as a fairer than
algorithmic decisions the interview
suggests that the gas between
algorithmic assumptions and human
behavior contributed to the perceive
unfairness of the algorithm algorithm
allocation so the fair division
algorithm implement equity based
fairness using individuals preferences
so that in the best case each
participant gets a tested they liked
most and they guessed don't get the test
they hate it but participant had a more
diverse concepts of fairness
some prefer equality everyone getting
just the same amano tasks
or getting a task randomly and they also
had a varying definitions of utility
like for example someone with the
algorithm to consider additional factors
such as individual skills or the time
that each task task takes so the in the
best case scenario the quality or a
duration of tasks are is also optimized
in the fair division algorithm also
assume that individuals are rational
actors who want to maximize their
benefit but in reality some of our
participants were willing to compromise
to help others so they value the
happiness of the group as well as their
own profit and they wanted to
accommodate other's needs so these
people wanted the algorithm to consider
this factor
or at least support this behavior so for
for example one participant said that he
wanted the software to collect the
reasons why people wanted certain
options so that he could later decide
whether to alter his share depending on
other people's reasons so I explained
how the gap between the algorithmic
assumptions and social context created
perceived unfairness in assignment
there's not like a why discussion was
effective so in the interviews people
said that discussion gave autonomy to
each group so that they could decide
what was fair for them and how the
utility was defined so some group
considered people's preferences and
skills while other group focus on everyo
working for the same duration of time in
discussion there is also social
transparency people could understand
each other's preferences and if they
didn't likes our interests they could
voice their concerns and make adjustment
to increase overall fairness so this
result shows that the lack of procedural
fairness and algorithmic decision might
be a reason why their decisions are
perceived as unfair procedural fairness
is the perceived fairness of the
decision making process in any different
places important role as the actual
outcome distributions so it has two main
components the quality of decision
making or whether the process allows
people to understand how the decision
was made in the quality of treatment or
social aspects of groups and the ways
people experience the interactions
so in our study discussion head of
really these two qualities where the
algorithm
decision had not so it shows the
takeaways computational guarantee loans
are not you know and maybe we should
think about our procedural fairness
around this algorithm
one comparison I'm curious if you
experimented with or thought about here
you're comparing sort of centralized
decision a very collaborative decision
made internally by a group comment if so
we really debated a lot on whether to
make it this cook like discussion base
or have a one Authority a person who is
giving them decisions and we for as a
first experiment because it was not the
people were attributing the they were
using it as a tool baby didn't say that
this is algorithm process giving me the
two in our contact so we use the
discussion but I love to like follow up
with our human decision maker
and follow suppose you actually have an
algorithm making a decision when you
have the group making decision except
that you don't actually report the
decision in the way that associates it
with the who actually makes the decision
with the perception of fairness be
influenced by how you thought it was
created in some
you could just randomly assign the
outcome to different procedures and
report it to currently and then maybe
the whole thing about perceptions you
think it was done through
decision-making whether or not it was
you see what I'm getting suppose
supposed to algorithm says okay you're
going to go to Arizona and the decision
says you're going to go that you're here
any part of Nevada and if you swap the
outcomes but we say
[Music]
with the perception of fairness be based
not on the actual outcome just on the
process it's a fair point and I actually
wonder about that too like the all comes
from the algorithm versus discussion
would they
he outcome is so very a lot in the way
the allocation decision was made just
based on the interviews I had a strong
feeling that it was about the
transparency and they are seeing what's
happening where its algorithm you just
get a result and you don't know what's
going on so in our inner dance that is
true so there's a huge I mean you lose
of control is a huge field in psychology
and even though you don't have control
if you feel like you're control you will
feel better about it
I think there is an ethical discussion
which I have whether like how much
mutual actually leverage image of
control or think about how to give the
actual control
so we've been reading a lot of papers on
procedural justice from like law
psychology and then we are working on
mapping all important factors that we
should consider along the process of
algorithmic decision for example like
there is a two kinds of things that we
can explain in algorithm one it's a
standard or what algorithms they are
using or what they write is based on but
also there is a different diff
transparents can be applied to decision
outcomes and I will explain later that
maybe the transparency of standards
algorithm may have a slightly different
impact on how people perceive do the
algorithm with decisions and the other
level is whether people have control
over the decision making process the
reason is for example the algorithm
itself or just the outcomes that they
get for example you get on some
assignment and then you have a chance to
appeal or swap it with another so there
would be another person about control
and the third one is general principles
it's also aspects of this process where
the decision makers have a good
intention toward the people who have or
affected by whether it's consistent and
whether it is related your comment on
like control like Elizabeth control
or just whether people have it - a
chance to just voice their concern even
though they cannot actually change the
outcome so in the next study we actually
try to look at how can we actually give
people over the algorithm is a control
over the algorithm then making this
manager all decisions and how can we
actually make this algorithm its sumer
transparent so for the remaining time I
will probably focus on this second
project so here our first a propose a
participatory framework that we call we
build AI and they all present a case
study in the context of on-demand
donation transportation service
so the key idea of our framework is that
we build a computational model they
represent each individual stakeholders
and to have that model negotiate or vote
on its individual via so this works like
a group of people making a decision
together like you saw in our discussion
based condition in the first study but
instead of an actual individual in the
room virtual computational models of
each individual decision making process
will make a group decision for each
algorithm it decisions so our framework
consists of four steps and I'll explain
these in more detail in our case study
so our case study was done it with a
real nonprofit called R for 1/2 for
rescue
it is organization like uber for charity
so they take food donation from donor
such as grocery store and retail stores
and also keep them to nonprofit they
help underserved food insecure
communities so example include food
pantries or homeless shelters and public
housing communities and they use an app
to coordinate volunteers to pick up and
deliver the donation to the nonprofit
and the organization has been quite
successful they have about 800 donor and
recipient organizations and have a pool
of thousands of volunteers and they are
expanding their model into 4 other
cities including San Francisco and
Philadelphia
so this profit wanted to introduce an
algorithm allocation system for two
reasons the one is to offload dispatcher
or workload the other one is that to
improve equity in their donation
distribution the current donation
distribution is quite skewed 20%
recipient organization getting 70% of
donations because allocation decisions
are often made for convenience by human
decision makers so in designing this
allocation algorithm we focused on the
trade-off between the equity and
efficiency so in other word so we focus
on this because it's a fundamental
challenge that we deal with in our
capitalist democratic societies
and also he requires a normative
approach in other words a human is to
define how to balance these competing
factors because there's no fundamental
right balance between the two and we
cannot just determine purely through
optimizations so in this contact this
design choice can have different impacts
on different stakeholders for example
let's say these allocation algorithm
prioritizes efficiency and give donation
to recipients are closest to donors and
it would be convenient for volunteers
too because they don't have to drive
long but it means that donation
distribution will be skewed because
donors are often located in wealthy area
so recipient in wealthy area will get
more donations but on the other hand if
the allocation algorithm prioritize its
equity recipients with greater needs may
receive more but this may increase the
distance they volunteer need to drive as
well as the effort for phone to rescue
to span in recruiting the volunteers so
we wanted to find a collective solution
to this trade-off so that the algorithm
doesn't make decision that this was very
Zara stakeholders in an unacceptable way
and all stakeholders will be more
motivated to continue participating in
the service if they feel their needs are
respected so - they say and we use the
framework to build the algorithm with
four types of foreign - for rescue our
stakeholders and I'll walk you through
each step of our framework application
the first day was to determine what
features or input information the
algorithm should use based on the
feedback from the stakeholders so for
this we conduct the interviews with
these stakeholders to understand what
factors they thought the ologies
algorithm should consider so for example
poverty rate of is a one indicator of
client needs distance between the
recipient and donor as a metrics of it
efficiency and next we use these
features to model people's individual
beliefs we use two method iteratively
the first method was machine learning
based so which
the model using participants answers to
pairwise comparison scenario that showed
two recipients who vary along the
features from step one so you see that
we use seven factors and then we
presented the pairwise comparison aerial
so people can choose which recipients
should give donations we also used other
method where was more explicitly rule
specification and we went for a really
high-tech and asked people to place
weights on a postal card so that they
can actually write till to tell us like
how much weight each factor should have
and we we use these two method
iteratively or intentionally so that
people could use the bottom all pairwise
comparisons to get more familiar with
the scenarios but also tell us what they
think should happen in a more direct way
speaking for themselves right saying
what they would like to have one
clarification is always of all
volunteers donors of recipient
organizations and of the front of you
rescue staff members we had for our
interviews we had a recipient
organizations client but for this one we
use the recipient organization
representative as a representative of
the client yeah if once participant
complete a model we visualize the two
model that they bill through the process
to and then ask them which model better
represent their model the Wow surprising
to me is this graph mainly complex well
we first used the factor that show we
used to simply craft than before but
then there was not enough for people to
understand what was going on so we here
we show their own x-axis we show the
input the range of the input variable
and then y-axis how much way it will
have and you see that for this one this
model that they created themselves
versus the answers to paranoid
comparison looks remarkably similar
for some participants the model that
they created themselves which is
presenting Orange versus model that they
trained looked really different so in
this kind of context participants were
were showing this graphic and then they
were asked to explain the difference and
asked them to they chose the model that
they think they were best represent
their model and at the end the final
model had over about eighty a percent
accuracy overall machine learning model
was more accurate but there were some
instances people wanted to choose a
bottle that they created I'm going to
not going to cover that in this talk
while happy to talk about if anyone is
interested in the once we build this
final individual model we implemented
that model for each participant in our
system so in our system these for each
incoming donation each individual model
that participant built in the previous
step
create a rank list of potential
recipients and these individual lists
were aggregated using a board of voting
row to create the final recommendation
list
the final step of the framework we
explain these algorithm recommendations
to participant to support the additional
makers operation but also they know that
how their participant was actually used
to create the final algorithmic
decisions so we show the overall voting
score how the different recipient
organization was ranked by different
stakeholder groups and then we
highlighted the factors that made this
recipient recommended in like you see in
this video we implemented this
recommendation and this is a super
system in the web application that this
organization uses so that for any
incoming donation they will see a list
of recommendations and where it's
located and why that's recommended
so this step concluded the algorithm a
building process so what do we learn
through this process so one of our like
initial hypothesis was that having
people involved in this algorithm
building process will improve the
perceived fairness of the algorithm
there it will motivate them to use the
service more exact era and the interview
suggests that actually we saw the effect
that we were intending to see so one of
my favorite quote from our participant
was that like these are everyone's brain
power who are deemed to be important
this decision it should be the most fair
that you could get and they also really
appreciated that the organization
considered all stakeholders feedback so
they improve it improve their trust in
the organization as well as the
algorithm so one uncertainty that we had
initially was yes we can open up this
bill algorithm building process
but what kind of outcome this open
process will lead to so we ran our
simulation using the five months
historic donation data and it shows that
the donation was more equally
distributed compared to how human
decision makers have been making
decisions so this is a genie plot that
shows that the blue one is the algorithm
your location in the the orange one
that's really skewed is the how human
decision maker have been making
decisions and it also shows that the
algorithm gives donation the blue line
are two areas with a higher poverty rate
compared to how human Digital maker has
been making decisions
there was a one unexpected finding for
me so it was that the experience of
making the individual model the step to
hello in itself had a significant effect
on the participant particularly their
awareness of the algorithmic capability
and then the organizational
inconsistency so because participant
became more aware of how algorithm work
by training it and then working on the
scoring activities they became more
accepting and less resistant to the idea
of using algorithm in the first place so
one surprising woman was when one
participant told us that unprompted he
now believes an algorithm who Harley so
he was very skeptical that algorithm
could make such a complex decision that
involved caring for other so he was not
sure where the algorithm can make such
decisions but if degree through the
step-by-step process and seeing that the
algorithm makes a decision the hewed of
making he thought that he now believes
algorithm can make such decisions
secondly the experience of making
allocation themselves had participants
develop more empathetic stand for the
organization they mentioned that they
now realized that the difficulty that
they for want of a rescue of faces and
there might not be one perfect solution
for everyone so big this is important
change because it can improve our
people's tolerance and understanding of
the trade-off that are often in in
governance decisions finally building
the individual model also reveal
inconsistency in the organizational
decision-making so the step ever want to
rescue our soul that they have an
internal guideline they they rely on to
make this donation allocation since all
staff member ever according to the same
guideline they were surprised that their
models actually vary in the ways that
they weigh poverty organization size and
clients so these findings suggest that
these in this station method can itself
can be a useful tool for discovering
inconsistencies in organizational
practices
so to summarize our framework allows
people to collectively build an
algorithm for their own context and it
shows they can lead to Algren the better
reflects their principle that
stakeholders value and find fair and it
can improve algorithmic awareness for
the remaining few minute I'll briefly
talk about how we are thinking about
giving outcome control to the people and
going back to the original setup that we
I presented earlier we were kind of
thinking about how can we actually
improve the percy fairness in the
allocation setting that i discussed in
the first study so we built a web
application they explained this division
decisions there we first explain how
this fair division algorithm make the
fairness decision weighing different
people's utilities so it gives people
there's people a chance to understand
the algorithmic standard and then we
explain different people's importunities
and how this result in the final
allocations in this table form an
interface so our studies suggest that
initially the there are two groups
people who thought that their outcomes
are really fair because they got the
ones that they wanted most
versus people who thought that it was
really unfair because they didn't get it
by adding the transparency it actually
decreases the people who thought their
outcome was fair because they thought
that because they got the good outcome
they assumed that everyone else got the
good outcome and seeing the explanation
for themselves and for other they
realized oh actually I'm the one who got
the good deal but there are other people
who didn't get good deal so their
judgment of fairness decreased but at
the end we asked them to whether they to
adjust the kind of outcome themselves
then they universally increase the
perceived fairness
but we are aware that not all the cases
people can have this direct control over
the outcome that they get so in then we
didn't we also found on a lot of
unexpected findings about transparency
for example if we because we made it
algorithm verily transparent they
suddenly started blaming the input data
for the unfair outcome not the algorithm
or even sometimes for other participants
they had a weird preferences so that is
the why this is unfair cetera so the
preliminary findings suggest that these
reactions of these Pursy fairness is a
very complex nuanced phenomena and there
needs to be more studies so this is
three takeaways and thank you
[Applause]
I think that there is a really confusion
between two meanings of one is when I'm
controlling which also like I'm a judge
and I have to be cycled away and there
is one notion of certainty that I'm just
having resources and the other notion is
that we play both roles I think just
because we have one girl furnace for
both situations we tend to consider them
together where I think they're
completely separate not typically
illusion of control but it's really the
responsibility if I'm also hoping the
resources and I make different decisions
then when I have only a recipient it's
not about an illusion of control it's
about two different games that are
questioned so my short answer is I agree
with you this context especially that
not the proto for ask a case study but
lead the lab experiments were focused on
situation where this is a makers are
also affected by their decisions so I
agree that to our follow-up studies will
get different contexts where there's a
distinguished um maker who may have more
power or less power and then those who
are affected by them
[Applause]